when I remember driving up at the Comedy
Store and you were like I think you were
wearing a mask or something but you were
really worried about Koval this is when
we were texting every day texting every
yeah about covin and even I was like
Esther don't not yet not yet what did I
tell you what did I tell you you said
nothing's gonna happen you're fine
you're [ __ ] idiot for being scared
there's a billion people in China
everything's fine it's not coming here
and then Whitney join twit you were
Whitney basically ganged up on me I was
like oh yeah I would never say hey I was
extending the parking lot like shivering
of fear and Whitney is like you think
you're so special that you could get it
really made you feel bad but it actually
weirdly enough made me feel better
because then I went home and didn't have
so much fear about it I'm like well I
trust them and they're telling me not to
be scared you guys did end up being
wrong but you're not the only ones my
therapist told my therapist told me she
wanted to throw my hand sanitiser away
and I mean I ended up taking that last
trip to Vancouver that I was scared of
but I don't know yeah you guys you guys
were not scared we were traveling we
were in Hawaii I remember and I and I
texted you I said I'm gonna be the
guinea pig I'm gonna go without a mask
and I'm but I still had like sanitized
everything like my seat and I was still
really careful nothing happened to me so
I was like oh I think I'm good really
yeah
you think that you had it um no I don't
I never felt ill I had never got sick
not even from the flu or a cold but you
don't think there's a chance you like
had at asymptomatic um if I if we would
have it would have been from that travel
because as soon as lockdown happened we
were we haven't seen anybody sense but I
can tell you when it got real for me
right Tom Hanks remember when Tom Hanks
we're like Tom Hanks who we [ __ ] up we
were I was like [ __ ] Tom Hanks for
escamole [ __ ] were dead that was like
the best PR for Kovan yeah yeah yeah and
that day that Tom Hanks announced it
that morning I was supposed to fly to
Montreal and I
I know I just told you guys this when
you were over but like I was supposed to
fly it to Montreal and I woke up and
Mike the car service was there so I was
going to work and I just said like I
can't go I called my agent I was like
how bad is this if I cancel like this I
know this is so unlike me and it's crazy
and then I remember Dave woke up and
he's like wow so you're [ __ ] crazy
you're still here but then by the end of
the day that like so in the morning I
looked absolutely crazy to everyone by
the end of the day Tom Hanks had it then
eh shut the season down oh wow like if I
was in Canada right now and then here's
the second person that made a real real
for me ddk Daniel they came because I
had been to his house in Hawaii two
weeks but two weeks before in Super Bowl
I went to his house I've never seen a
Super Bowl I didn't even know what
support I'm not kidding me I didn't know
what the [ __ ] support it was at the time
they're like Super Bowl he called me a
Super Bowl would you think I go is it a
food is it a big bowl of food like
organic super food right I went over and
there was a football game if you guys
don't know yeah it's a football game and
it's the last football game of the
season where the two top people do it
after that we shared a flight with him
yeah yeah before that's how I got to the
[ __ ] Hawaii that no I know the flight
I know that's how I got to the flight
with the flight but that's how I got to
his house because we ran into each other
at the airport yeah and he's like hey
you know maybe you can come over for the
Superbowl
and I'm like whatever and then he called
me and then that's went over to his
house and then when he got it I was like
oh this is real Wow like anybody can get
it you know now you know ddk recover
either have you seen his body yeah it's
so nice how long do you think it would
take for you to get to ddk body level I
think is I'm at the point of no return
three months no not three months I'm at
the point of no return I don't have also
the structure he has welcome I'll did ya
become of kamyelle is his
structure I believe I believe that God
makes certain you know I've said this
before right